maybe people know this maybe they don't
but the term mexic
was or is a misogynistic term i lost my
mother to this and
obviously i'm determined not to lose the
mother to my children to the same thing
prince harry slamming the term mexic
while also opening up about his late
mother over here all of the headlines
are dominated by one word mexic this
insinuation being that she is
responsible for this move she is
responsible for pulling prince harry
over to north america the duke of sussex
took part in a virtual panel for wired
on tuesday promoting awareness about the
danger of misinformation in the media we
know that
a small group of accounts
are allowed to create a huge amount of
chaos online and destruction and without
any consequence whatsoever part of that
destruction harry said led to the press
adopting the phrase mexi in early 2020.
in the wake of the couple's announcement
that they were stepping away from their
royal duties in fact the term and maybe
people know this maybe they don't but
the term
mexic
was or is a misogynistic term um and it
was created by a troll amplified by
royal correspondents and it grew and
grew and grew onto mainstream media
but it began
with a troll as harry sees it this is an
issue that predates the internet and
social media it's important to recognize
this problem it did not originate on
social media and you do not need to be
online to be affected as i said um i
learned from a very early age that the
incentives of publishing are not
necessarily aligned with the incentives
of truth the prince took his point
further referencing the death of his
mother princess diana harry was 12 years
old when the people's princess died in a
car accident in 1997 after being chased
by members of the paparazzi my
experience i guess has been more
pre-social media around
the uk press who sadly conflate profit
with purpose so i know the story all too
well i lost my mother to this
um this self-manufactured
rabidness and
obviously i'm determined not to lose the
mother to my children to the same thing
harry also referenced a new study that
examined online hate speech about megan
let's pull up some stats here just so i
get it right more than 70
of the hate speech about my wife on
twitter could be traced to fewer than 50
accounts um perhaps the most troubling
part of this is the number of british
journalists interacting with and
amplifying the hate and the lies
but they regurgitate these lies as truth
meanwhile on tuesday megan was also
getting candid about the royal couple's
portrayal in the media i've read great
things about you as a boss and if you
read the tabloids you can read all sorts
of crazy things about being a boss well
firstly i would urge you not to read
tabloids um because i don't think that's
healthy for anyone hopefully one day
they come with a warning label like
cigarettes do like this is toxic for
your mental health megan took part in
the new york times deal book summit a
conversation focused on bridging the gap
in the workplace for women where she
echoed harry's concerns about social
media i think there is really legitimate
media but at the moment you see
in many ways social media feeding into
that so it becomes a race to the bottom
i think the challenging piece there is
that in many ways
because it is so quick and and rapid in
how it's being delivered it's about
creating the news rather than reporting
the news but the damaging effects of
that specifically for women especially
for young girls is impossible to even
quantify
[Music]